what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports last week we
brought you the top 10 one taps in csgo
now that included rightful one taps and
one DS but you guys let us know in the
comments section that we should do an
entire list devoted to just one deeds
well you asked and we delivered before
we get into it though I'm gonna need you
to buy up that deagol and give the
subscribe button just one tap thank you
very much without further ado here are
the top 10 one deeds and csgo kicking
off our list is cold Zahra at IEM
Auckland 2016 cold caught an attacking
RPK with the digue before showing a
falling Shox why he's one of the best
players in the world last time this
happened it was cut way too close
dropping shots without him even touching
the ground that is at number 9 we've got
Nico's three K against g2 at Dreamhack
cluj-napoca
2015 the Bosnian superstar used his
trusty boob to completely shut down an
onslaught of g2 players
this happened that Nikko delivering
must've leaked of mass plus if he would
if he blinks he would have missed that
one
Nikko Stella stop coming in at number
eight is automatic versus complexity at
Dreamhack Montreal 2017 automatic showed
off his stealth skills while taking a
sight catching two off-guard CTS with
one deke he followed that up by out
aiming to more complexity players
grabbing himself for kills with only
five shots flex needle playing very
patient still two players back by IV one
man long sight and there it is Hopkins
matic that's incredible for automatic as
he finds a third as well but how have
they let him walk in no one even looking
at a mate and they know they're against
crystals he's got four and just thinking
one of these rounds missed or was that
for head shots for I think he hits a
body shot hit yak so one body shot but
then follows it off either way you look
impressive okay how do they leave a man
completely open next up is simples
rotate at ESL one New York simple
surgically 1v1 for virtus pro players to
completely deflate their potential come
back alley off does with an eagle shot
lovely so the palm planted no kid does
have our Murphy can just grab at
eightgames gonna go that's enough he's
got two one taps he's feeling it deagle
shopton he's picked up at a cage well
then he's like biggest
[Applause]
didn't even look like you got a chance
for the diffuse to go to 14 for Navi
finally know how they get a bit of that
snacks imagine working for them simple
with a desert eagle coming in at number
6 another automatic clip this time
against gambit the c9 player once again
showed off some slick deeds dismantling
the CIS teams by around at Dreamhack
open winter 2016 sack up over toward
beat to up toward oh I was gonna say
automatic finds a third that was just
godlike pushing offshore the first ones
pretty standard then this is where it
gets interesting second it was great and
then the third even better that's so
lovely for them coming in at number five
key Arby's deagle clutch against Navi
just when natus Vincere thought they
could really pull away with the game in
comes key RB with the deagle the
astrologer and at three one digs in a
row and proceeded to finish off Edward
with the headshot securing the second
round win in the last 11x round called
fake the tec-9 neatly and dropped canopy
now in 1 vs. 4 oh my goodness
the father's been planted he goes back
in four seconds
mrs. a couple shots but he's wasting
valuable time edge was gonna push him
Kia be all you gonna pull off the right
are you serious
we've seen that legal do some impressive
work this tournament but I think that is
top-tier a 4k and one of the most
crucial rounds a thing that has in
complete disarray PR be that was
absolutely sick and number four we've
got taco dismantling astrologist be push
on mirage the sk gaming player evicted
the danes from apartments with his
superintendent mr. diggle's
not very good here on CT side of mirage
dennis it's gonna continue to man this
right here the grand finals who's it
ever gonna end
coming in at number three we've got
Dupree smothering faze clan at the IEM
katowice 2017 grand finals Dupree
completely derailed phase taking on the
whole team by himself with nothing but a
trusty needle works though
how sick is this gravity and now we're
getting pumped
[Applause]
okay Dupree that's starting to arrive
now they needed that round desperately
just as a dealer to work events and P do
fifties and Dupree with the ACE
phenomenal round from him look how good
that's what that thought headshot my god
so sick the runner-up on our list
goes to Nikko once again against Titan
at ESL pro league the French team lined
up for Nikko as he single-handedly
dropped the entire squad as they ran up
Highway to their death mouses by is
gonna be torn away from the very very by
side oh my god then justify one more the
Mali isn't gonna touch him and what has
just happened as deagle is on fire as
well Nikko is on fire five he recovers
the AEK as well let's just take a moment
to appreciate the beauty of this oh my
god it looks like so we've gone back to
source where the deagle becomes the orb
apparently but Nikko absolute class play
then capping off our list is Happy's
dboys what is there left to say about
this incredible play we all know it we
all love it it's happy single-handedly
destroying TSM the Pecan envious side
head well that's what happens when you
go around the corner happy with wanting
[Applause]
debris debris is like sweating bullets
[Applause]
I think I just broke my chair I might
need a new one
yeah I think I actually did this right
back there hold on let me get into it a
warith he sacrificed a chair for a round
that's gonna go down in history without
a doubt here this is a ridiculous
performance all right guys that's our
list now we know there are a lot of one
diegs out there but those are the 10 we
thought were the spiciest if you've got
an idea for a top 10 list you'd like to
see us do next time let us know in the
comments below thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]